[music]
Narrator:
On Thursday, Jan. 19, the Princeton University
Concert series presents Ensemble ACJW, featuring
Narrator:
musicians from The Academy at Carnegie Hall.
The concert will take place at Richardson
Narrator:
Auditorium in Alexander Hall.
Mariana Olaizola:
The Princeton University Concerts is a gem of Princeton tradition that has enriched
this campus for more than 100 years.
Scott Burnham:
We're going to hear music by Beethoven, Shostakovich
and the contemporary composer David Bruce.
Scott Burnham:
This is a high-energy event not to be missed.
Mariana Olaizola:
As a student sitting in this glamorous
Richardson Auditorium, it's a special moment
Mariana Olaizola:
amidst a crazy academic life. That we get
to experience some of the finest music making
Mariana Olaizola:
from vocal Renaissance music to ground-breaking
funky grooves like Time for Three is just
Mariana Olaizola:
an enormous, amazing gift that this University offers us.
Scott Burnham:
A lot of people have this image of Beethoven,
that he's a heaven-storming world-beater,
Scott Burnham:
and that he's deadly serious in a lot of his
compositions, with a knotted brow -- just
Scott Burnham:
think of those busts of Beethoven that you
often see -- but the piece that we're going
Scott Burnham:
to hear in this concert, the trio for
clarinet, cello and piano, opus 11, is
Scott Burnham:
a lot of fun, and it taps into a vein that
Beethoven worked a lot all during his career,
Scott Burnham:
but mostly during the early years, which was
popular music.
Mariana Olaizola:
I would say everyone should take advantage
of this opportunity.
Scott Burnham:
If you'd like to hear more about it, I'm going
to be talking with the performers on stage
Scott Burnham:
before the concert. I hope you can join us.